hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
we're back in the kitchen with another
kitchen unboxing today we're gonna be
unboxing and trying this out it is a
bb-8 waffle maker
not too long ago I did another waffle
making video but I actually just made an
omelet in a waffle maker oh my god what
do I do
I think I should probably try to make
actual waffles
bb-8 waffles this little waffle maker is
so cute let's open impeccable timing
oh my goodness so cute
bb-8 is still my absolute favorite like
I love Archer d2 his class like that
bb-8 just he was just there something
special about him oh yeah baby look at
that bb-8 plates up we're gonna be using
this it's pretty much the coolest thing
ever
they have it on Amazon that's where I
bought it why everything on Amazon I
don't leave the house I mean I do but
like I don't this is this quick shake
and pour not sponsored but awesome
you pretty much pour water in here one
and a half cups of cold water to be
precise you put the lid back on and you
shake it and you're done
oh oh okay that's just right there why
should I say 1/2 cup water into our
beautiful little container
lid on turn bottle upside down tap lid
shake container hard for 30 seconds oh
it hurts hey you've been working out no
I just been making waffles baby with
this pancake batter is that the same
thing as the hustle think so oh well
maybe we're making pancakes
you might be making pancakes today
you're wondering the scene are you an
idiot
yes I am depends on the topic okay I
think got 30 seconds I can count there's
a little switch here so bb-8 is super
hot right now so we're gonna spray him
up
always always spray your workspace all
right guys enough so guys we just pour
this in and see what happens
I think that's enough
this is definitely pancakes so that's
overflowing hmm is it do is it it's just
that's it it's doing its thing hmm
that still says it was preheating but
that looked pretty hot to me how long am
I supposed to wait what do you think do
you think it's done like six minutes no
I don't know a waffles I think we're
making pancakes I'm not sure
let's look oh oh oh
maybe a little bit longer for the next
one maybe it is five or six minutes it's
definitely not one minute smells like
plastic
like a rubber burning his BB aids body
inside here am I actually burning his
plastic body although real VBA it was
like more of a metal aluminum I wonder
what he was made of oh no oh God
oh boy oh thing
he looks incredible I'm proud I don't
eat the first one cuz this is the first
time that I'm using this and it smells
awful let's do another one second time's
the charm
except to say third maybe the third time
second third time I think I put a little
too much in the last time I'm gonna try
to do a little less and hope for the
best that might have not been enough or
it might have been perfect Aunt Jemima
she never did me wrong
[Music]
oh my god he's perfect he's almost
perfect I want this to be a golden brown
I want him to be toasted super toasted
why do I keep touching it it's hot I
think that's good mother
freaking Star Wars good galaxy it's not
quite perfect but I'm sorry oh he looks
so good
oh my goodness look at that that is pure
beauty while I make one more I'm gonna
do a taste test of him
alright let's taste this delicious
delectable bb-8 yeah this is still a
little doughy I'm gonna leave him in
there for a few more minutes
still not crispy bb-8 beanie basic
let's get him out yeah oh god this is
still like dough so this is definitely a
better consistency I think like that
looks much better
let's just shave off these extra little
sides and we're gonna have a successful
bb-8 treat here's our beautiful bb-8
here's our delicious syrup syrup syrup
however you pronounce it lather him up
real good
let's eat little baby's head oh look
it's baby body baby brain I got you
that's bebe Rexha real oh my god it's
incredible I've been making so many
really good tasting things on my channel
that I don't know who I am anymore I
don't know my own self
like I couldn't mess this up and I
didn't I didn't I did a great job
patting my own self on my own back
Wow thank you guys so much for watching
this was super fun and I'm extremely
happy with how this turned out I'll put
a link in the description where you can
get this if you want to get it at the
spawn Amazon even though I know it's not
the newest Star Wars but excuse well
even the newest Star Wars isn't actually
the newest Star Wars with the newest
wrote one is actually it no spoilers but
anyway see you guys later thanks for
watching leave me some comments below
let me know what you'd like me to make
next and that's it breakfast is served
may the force be with you
[Music]
you